there's a good reason why the new Mad
Max game occasionally resembles this
year's Mad Max fury road
it's a canonical prequel that pits you
against scabrous scrotus son of the
film's sinister immortan joe driving is
central to life in the wasteland and is
the basis for the game's best moments -
the combination of an intriguing world
and great car combat makes playing Mad
Max an occasional joy but shallow ground
combat and a handful of other missteps
ultimately lead to disappointment at the
start of the game scrotus and a pack of
his gangly war boys steal your beloved
car the Interceptor leaving you
empty-handed
however fortune smiles upon you in a
golem like mechanic by the name of Chum
Bucket crosses your path and joins your
fight he's a whiz with both a wrench and
a harpoon making him the perfect
companion in the hard driving and
violent wasteland while you're on the
road it's normal to be confronted by
three or four enemy cars at once and
there's some carry enemies that will try
to hop onto your car you can resort to
your trusty shotgun or pull over and
fight it out with your fists watching
max manhandle thugs can be entertaining
but the combat controls are rudimentary
at best we're mashing 1 button dishes
out contextual attacks and another
parries attacks when an enemy has an
icon flashing over their head the combat
system is so simple at its core that
nearly every fight can be won by
alternatively tapping attack and parry
save for a few boss fights when you have
to roll out of harm's way
it's a none rewarding experience overall
that's far too easy to exploit
oh wait James don't get too excited we
need to get the hell out of here oh the
story progresses as max upgrades his car
with new parts either by completing
fetch quests or dismantling enemy
outposts on foot after a new part is
unlocked you purchase it using scrap
metal that you collect around the world
which you primarily acquire from glowing
piles that are sparingly strewn about
the wasteland these piles include
massive car parts which you can
conveniently stick in your pocket it's
helpful that you can carry multiple cars
worth of metal on your person but it
doesn't make much sense
max can increase his efficiency as a
scavenger by trading in coins to a
mystic that resides on top of certain
cliffs he's an odd duck
but like Chum his peculiarities add to
the world's mythology in a great way
though some of his gifts diminish the
threat of the wasteland by artificially
boosting your gathering abilities Mad
Max is rife with logical inconsistencies
that pull you out of the world and
negate your supposed struggle to survive
being run over by a car should
theoretically kill you outright but
you're damaged more by the punch of a
withered nomad than by the mass of a
three-ton war machine if you're a sloppy
fighter a few punches is all it takes to
bite the dust but you can somehow enjoy
getting run over by a car five or six
times before you have to worry about
your health in fact you get so good at
being struck by cars that you eventually
learn unofficially how to jump onto the
windshield of an oncoming vehicle to
perform a triple misty flip and land
gracefully on your feet you can also
apparently stand in fire without getting
hurt but only sometimes experience has
taught me that a burning car isn't as
hot as a flamethrower though you're told
that you need to collect vital resources
such as water and food I never noticed
any gradual deleterious impacts to my
health for me exposed to the wasteland
if anything these resources were used
for recovering health after a
particularly challenging vehicle battle
bad max where it's then sooner rather
than later as quests become more
repetitive in the wasteland more
unbelievable thankfully the final battle
forces you to chase down a convoy and
dismantle scrotus his massive war rig
regular car combat is fun but the scale
of the war rig and the relentless nature
of scrotus is horde make this battle
truly memorable the promise of a Mad Max
game is participating in its harsh
reality this Mad Max with over game
design flaws and a lack of consistency
fails to properly capture the true
spirit of the wasteland or Max's
character it's a shame because the world
is beautiful grim and fascinating some
interesting characters impressive
environments and great car combat draw
you in and incentivize you to keep going
but it's when you get out of the car
that things begin to fall apart combat
system is too dumbed down to enjoy and
repetitive activities get old very fast
Mad Max is too focused on providing you
with an open world that's filled with
missions and not focused enough on
making those missions worth playing
gonna hurry up